is the question everyone wants the
answer to it
what is the single biggest killer of
relationships in the modern age
let's talk about sex today's podcast is
very very different but incredibly
incredibly important
today i'm sitting down with kate moyle
who is a sex therapist
and a relationship therapist to talk
about some of the taboos topics
which we don't normally discuss things
like erectile dysfunction
sexual inadequacies issues we all have
in our relationships and sex lives
the single biggest killer of
relationships in 2021
sexual anxiety how to keep a sexual
relationship exciting
and everything in between i'm going to
share some very personal sexual stories
that i've never shared before some of
the things i've gone well and some of
the problems that i've had that have
caused relationships that have meant the
world to me to end this is a very
very honest open podcast today you know
this is why this is called the diary
of a ceo and kate is the perfect person
to put them to
so i think you're going to enjoy this
conversation i certainly did
i feel very vulnerable sharing some of
these stories with you
but as i always say just keep it to
yourself so without further ado this is
the diary of a ceo
i hope nobody's listening but if you are
then please keep this to yourself
sex i think i think it's fair to say
that
everybody has some kind of
challenge with sex at least some point
you know at least at some point within
their life
and i am no different in fact my last
relationship
which was a very i thought i i genuinely
at one point thought that was going to
be my wife
um the reason that relationship broke
down was because
of a sexual issue and a sexual issue
that showed up about seven or eight
months into the relationship
and um long story short i know this
isn't a therapy session but it kind of
is as well
um at some point seven eight months into
our relationship she told me that she
didn't like having sex
and i didn't know what that meant and as
a guy that's never experienced that in
my life
um i read into it probably in
the wrong way but it definitely made me
insecure i was like what you don't like
having sex how's that possible
and i thought that was some kind of um
condemnation on me i thought that was
something negative towards me or
something that i was doing wrong and i
tried
various things i tried to to be a bit
more under you know listen a little bit
more to what she wanted and how she
wanted it
and then it you know it progressively
got to a point where
i was getting in bed and i was [ __ ]
myself
because you don't want to once you get
rejected i've never been like i've never
gone to have sex with someone in my life
and been rejected in that way and so you
get in bed and you don't want to
even ask them for sex because you might
take an l and you don't want to take
that l
and then how how the hell am i meant to
get an erection as a guy
when i'm that [ __ ] scared of
rejection
and eventually long story short we're in
um we're away one time and
the same issue happened and she we were
having sex and i clearly i was looking
at her thinking she clearly isn't
enjoying this at all
and we stopped she started crying she
said
um i've got a problem um she said like
uh you know i just don't enjoy sex i
need to like address it
i said to her you want to talk about it
she said i'm not comfortable talking
about sex with you
even though we've been in a relationship
for a year and i left and then i broke
up with her
and i do regret breaking up with her
because
um i did so maybe too flippantly
and i didn't understand it and i didn't
think it was fixable and i didn't know
how to fix it and
yeah sorry for my brain you know my
dumping that on you but good place to
start no i think and
you know so much of what you've just
said there's so many points there that
you know i hear all the time so
difficulties with desire
struggles with communication struggles
with knowing like where to start in
terms of talking about it
anxiety you know all of these points
which can kind of get in the bedroom
with us or be in bed with us
and we just don't know how we're
meant to address them we don't know what
we're meant to do about them
and we all feel that sense of what am i
doing wrong here or what's wrong with me
do i have a problem am i broken you know
all of these phrases and actually
working with all of the information that
you've just given me
you know as an example we can kind of
target or work with
each of those problems in an individual
way which isn't
terrifying for people which doesn't
create more anxiety which doesn't damage
self-esteem
but we don't have those conversations in
a bigger
more normalizing way yeah and i think
one of the biggest things that i talk
about
is this idea that sex like everything
else across our lives has good days
bad days average days variability but we
expect there to be this
constant and we expect it to be
protected from everything else that we
have going on in our lives and that just
isn't the case but and somewhat
automatically right like we kind of
expected to take care of itself
yeah and relationships as well we kind
of expect that
you know once they're good they're
always good that they
shouldn't falter that we shouldn't have
to work at them that
they shouldn't struggle and i think that
there's such
a problem with that as a basic
foundation message around sex and
relationships
how do you refrain that then how do i
reframe my thinking in order to make
sure that
i'm i guess that is a reframing of my
thinking if i think that this thing
isn't going to take care of itself
and it needs to be worked on like
everything else in my life i guess
that's the answer to keeping it exciting
yeah i mean i think there's just a
normalizing of the fact that
our sex lives and our relationships are
in the context of us
they're not isolated they're not
protected they don't have their own kind
of
special area where they aren't impacted
by
how we feel about ourselves stress
anxiety our health our mental health
you know physically what's going on for
us um psychologically what's going on
for us but
why don't we just give ourselves a break
and but you know what
we're not perfect or good or great at
everything else we do
all the time so why would we be here i
don't
think you know i think as professionals
we often talk about like why aren't we
applying the logic
that we apply everywhere else in our
lives
to this this part of our lives and in
that particular case with me and my
this this particular person um she
turned to me i remember we were away one
time and she said to me
you know there's loads of people that
are like me that don't have like a high
libido or whatever
and i have just never encountered these
people in my experiences so i thought oh
that's rubbish
was she right yes yes and how right is
she
very right and you know we understand
that you know this is a huge part of the
conversation
around sex lives at the moment and
sexual wellness at the moment is
this idea about desire desire's not a
fixed concept
that we're born with we're not kind of
given or
holding a set amount it's not like we
kind of have an amount and we like use
it up
it is context dependent it's responsive
and
we understand that it changes but
actually how we can change that within
kind of take power of our own i suppose
or change that within the context that
we're in how we can feel
in control of that is based in
almost how we define it or how we
understand it ourselves and there's a
huge
problem we're just thinking okay well i
had it now i don't have it in the same
way anymore
so what's wrong with me or
what's broken or what changed or what's
not working here rather than
if i reframe my understanding my
thinking about this it makes a lot more
sense and it takes the pressure off and
when the pressure's off
then i can work with this in a more
pleasure focused enjoyable way
rather than an anxiety provoking and
stressful way
what should i have done so the first
time she turns to me she says
steve i'm just not that interested
because what it was is we're in bed
and we're away on a holiday and i like
you know just i don't know what i do
whatever i do to
to let someone know that when i have sex
i don't know stroke their arm or
whatever
i did whatever i do and she was just
like
nah and what should i have done then
because you know
i think a lot of people would take that
as a
bit of an l and i certainly did i was
like what i was and i was angry as well
not like visibly angry not like you know
hitting with a pillow or anything but i
was like i turned i remember turning
away and thinking
you know like because i'd never
experienced that before i've never
experienced that like
it is a form of rejection it's like a
form of it's a
kick in the self-esteem what should i
have done
well i think you know i can't talk to
what was going on for you two
like kind of in in that moment then but
you know
the biggest problem that couples in
situations like that have
is assumption so as you said like this
is the kick in the teeth for me like
that hurts i feel rejected
so we internalize and actually the best
way for us to deal with something like
that
is to try and explain to try and move
away from assumption
to explanation to understanding because
actually if we can have a conversation
which
opens up and you know we you hear sex
next relationship experts talk about
communication being
you know the kind of biggest pillar of
sexual wellness or sexual well-being and
assumption kind of and the gap between
expectations and reality
is actually the biggest place that we
have a lot of these problems and i think
that it
feels like you know that's a good
example of that happening
fast forward four months uh the same
sort of
issue happened and she turned to me and
this is when i thought it was completely
over
is she said to me i'm not comfortable
with talking to you about sex
right and we've been together for a year
and i thought well if we can't talk
about it
and i don't really understand the issue
and you're not willing to talk about it
then we are [ __ ] and i thought and
that's when i left
i left that country um soon after and
i broke up with her maybe like i don't
know two three weeks later
because i thought if we can't talk about
it then how do we fix the situation
but i do regret it because i think i
reflect and i think
i don't want to be the type of guy
generally that when they care about
someone will walk away from it so easily
and i think i should have made a more
active effort to try and support
as you say and understand maybe but
i would say sometimes the hardest person
to talk to about sex is the person we're
having it with
yeah because of it's so loaded
it's so like intimate it's so vulnerable
and also
the fear of getting it wrong or making
it worse
or leading our partners on or going in
the wrong direction or
us not being able to unhear what we've
heard or unsay what we've said
so actually you know that natural human
response to
feeling anxiety around something is
avoidance you know we don't tend to
approach the sources of our anxiety
unless we're trying really hard
to hone in on it or focus on it our most
natural instinct is
i don't want to go there you know like
it's just easier to keep the status quo
even if that status quo
isn't working and so it's
it's about thinking about how do we how
do we help people
to approach that source of anxiety or
feel empowered
to change their conversation around sex
because
it's really it's really hard it's like
talking in a language that
we've not been taught you know we're not
taught how to have these conversations
we're not taught to be comfortable about
these conversations we're not taught
that sex is normalized as a topic and
then
we're expected to all be experts and
that our partners
are going to be experts and we're all
expecting that from each other and then
when it doesn't work
you know we have no solutions or ways of
knowing
how to deal with it now some of us
muddle through we kind of work it out
we're like okay well
let's try this or think about this or
take expert advice or listen to a
podcast or read a book or
get the information and we can kind of
work our way through it but for a lot of
us that's way too intimidating you know
sex feels
like an off the record you know off the
table topic
how do you bring on the table how do and
i'm presuming that
couples that are successful in the
bedroom are those that
bring it on the table to some degree is
that a fair assumption or
yeah i think that's definitely a fair
assumption i think that
you know it takes the courage to do it
it takes the kind of sitting in the
uncomfortable it might be quite anxiety
breaking obviously some people kind of
seek out therapy or external advice or
someone that can help them
manage those conversations or they might
do it in their
own way so it might be kind of reading a
book and sharing that with each other
or listening to a ted talk and then
sharing that with each other and using
that as a
springboard to have that conversation
but i would say it's
talking about it outside of the bedroom
is the biggest way to
put it on the table and is it possible
to be just like sexually incompatible
with someone yeah i think it is and the
way it's think you know impossible
possible to be incompatible with
anything else
but what we can also do is you know when
we have different interests or different
preferences in other areas of our lives
we can work together to negotiate that
to manage that to kind of
work to each other's kind of preferences
or and kind of switch that around or
manage that
manage that kind of relational bit that
kind of bit in between
and it is possible to do that with sex
but also for some people
they might have deal breakers and they
might not be able to meet those for each
other
this is i don't know if this is too much
information but i don't think i care
um i i remember one day as well i tried
to introduce because i typically when i
have sex i typically use
a lot of additional apparatus so i'll
use all kinds of stuff i don't care like
i'll use handcuffs and all kinds of
ropes and toys and whatever else and i
remember trying to introduce something
like that because i thought maybe it
would make it a little bit more
interesting for her
and um she was like absolutely not she
she said to me that she thought i think
it was a vibrator she
thought a vibrator was for old people
and you know i'm already up i'm really
up against it here that's so i'm trying
to
like do something to help and when she
said that i just thought like maybe we
are just like sexually incompatible
maybe
just we just speak two different
languages here so
i don't know but you know like sometimes
one part nina
what i would say is it's actually more
common for couples to not be perfectly
sexually matched
yeah than it is for them to be like
perfectly sexually matched in every way
and for some people they are more ready
to try something or you know
they might be the one that leads
something and then the other partner
kind of catches up or
it's really in about also kind of like
how we perceive what our partner is
suggesting
or how we what we think that means
because one of the things about
sex is we have this idea as humans about
like metacognition like we think about
our thoughts
we think about what that our thoughts
mean and
i think it's really really apparent when
it comes to sex and relationships
because we're trying to constantly
analyze what's happening or as you said
kind of looking out for like the risk of
rejection or the fear of rejection we're
trying to understand
what that means about us or what that
means about them or what it means about
our relationship and so we're
always trying to i suppose think about
like what's going on
and the wider context or meaning of that
now when it comes to sex
we're already in a culture and a society
where it's a bit
taboo where it's quite stigmatized where
we don't necessarily
want to kind of step outside the norms
or the expectations because what does
that mean about us
as a person i you know since that um
whole
event i you know we we spoke a little
bit after we broke up and she she told
me that was actually the first time she
told me that she had like a low libido
and i actually didn't really understand
what that meant so i googled it
but then i started talking to some
friends about it specifically some male
friends
and i had another male friend say to me
one of my best friends said to me that
he also had the same problem where he
just lost his um
sexual desire um in you know when he got
to a certain age which i i was
shocked about because you don't people
don't have these conversations so you
don't think it happens
so when we encounter it whether it's in
the bedroom or wherever else
um yeah it really feels like a real
anomaly but
how how common is low libido and also
what are the
what are the typical causes of someone
having a low libido i think really
common
and i think you know like so much of the
stuff we don't
have huge and huge amounts of at least
up to date like sex research so you know
it's something that people are really
trying to kind of develop in the space
but what we understand when we think
about
desire so we've got desire and we've got
arousal so arousal the body's physical
ability to kind of prepare for sex the
desire the want to be
sexual and what we understand is that
it typically changes across
relationships
and what feels really difficult about it
is that at the start of relationships
when everything is new and exciting
we're getting to know each other we're
exploring
it feels like desire is very high we're
kind of leaning into that because it's a
way of getting to know each other a way
of connecting with that person
and it's kind of what we understand is
it's triggered i suppose
a lot because a lot of the situations we
find ourselves in
are novel are kind of tuning into also
the area of our brain that likes the new
things that likes the excitement
and we have that sense of wanting to get
closer to that person wanting to get to
know them now
also what we see particularly this is
with a relationship focus
is there's like exchange of kind of like
novelty newness the unknown exploration
for like routine security safety getting
to know someone so we kind of see these
things
switching out almost and so
it's just actually that as we get kind
of more used to each other
there are less of those kind of
triggering like exciting moments which
are where desire can tend to thrive and
what we need to do is
perhaps just slightly more consciously
or with a bit more of an effort
put in the time to create those spaces
now chuck in i mean you know the year
we've found
ourselves in where no one's had any kind
of personal space or independence
or ability to go away and come back
together kind of change of context but
technology the kind of well third and
fourth if there's two people in the
relationship
wheels that are constantly taking our
attention kind of demanding us
you know distracting us so we're missing
signals from our partners we're missing
those kind of i suppose quality time
moments we're constantly notified or
we're distracted
and actually then it's harder for us
to give each other our full attention to
kind of sit down and focus on each other
to have the things that promote
connection eye contact touch we're
constantly kind of
looking around and connecting i suppose
with everyone apart from the person
actually that we're it creates a barrier
and so how do you know you get five 10
15 20 years into relationship
um and you've started to get you know
secure and
things are predictable how do you this
is probably the most
you know popular question i'm sure you
get which is like how do you keep it
fresh what advice would you give me to
keep my sex life with a partner i've
been with for x amount of years
still fresh exciting and uh yeah
exploratory
um yeah i think it's i mean it's the
question everyone wants the answer
right it's it is about
a.s first thing acknowledging that it
might
be different to how it used to be so
again one of the biggest hurdles people
can get kind of tripped over on is it's
not the same
as it used to be or it changed now
why does that mean it's worse you know
actually perhaps the quality of the sex
that people might be having might be
better because
they know each other better they
understand each other's bodies better
they feel more in tune with each other
so it's understanding that you might be
in a different phase
or stage and that's okay it doesn't have
to be
you know that famous phrase the
honeymoon period that kind of everybody
quotes or goes back to so i think that
is one thing
and i think actually kind of carving out
the time and the space and the effort
and not seeing that as a bad thing not
seeing that
as problematic that we have to be a bit
more conscious of that part of our
relationships
is a huge huge factor because what
the kind of common narrative we see in
like society i suppose is
if i have to make an effort for this
then there must be something wrong with
that because sex
should be spontaneous should be
something that just happened
that's what it says in the movies which
is part of the problem right because
that's one of the most easily accessible
visual
versions of sex that we have we don't
see into other people's sex lives in the
same way now what we do see
is social media or pictures of couples
or images of couples or
and we make assumptions about
them we make assumptions about they look
happy but they have great sex yeah in
porn it's just like the gardener's like
outside and then
eli comes in and the husband's away and
then like it's just
boom perfect lasts an hour everyone
looks like they're having a great time
but one of the one of the best phrases
that i heard and you know um
is trying to learn about sex from porn
is like learning to drive from watching
the fast and the furious
and it's one of the things that i go
back to i wish i knew you said it and if
you know please
tell me so you can claim it um but
porn wasn't designed as an educational
tool
but a lot of people have used it as one
and that's again i mean like every man
ever and also women to be fair like i
think men have this bias where we think
women don't watch porn
but then you ask a woman you know and
i've asked several of my ex-girlfriends
if they've watched porn and oh yeah
they do some of them do but i'd say and
this is a general
and i'd love you to correct me here
because i i'd love to not be i love to
be corrected on
things like this where i'm so naive i i
tend to believe that like 90
of my male friends watch porn and then i
think it's probably like 50 of my female
friends
do you know the numbers is that i don't
know the numbers but i
you know we know that women watch porn
we know that there are also a huge rise
of like female-friendly female-focused
pornography platforms kind of coming
forward and i think that
a lot of those ideas again tie into
these old stereotypes and narratives
about like male sexuality and female
sexuality
and then you know we're trying to change
the conversation around this and i think
that it's also about
recognizing that they're not these kind
of like two like
so separate entities and actually that
we can understand
that we're all sexual creatures and we
all have our
own versions of sexuality and what that
doesn't mean is that
it has to again kind of line up with the
narratives that have always been there
which is like men do this women do this
but are there distinctions between um
sexual appetite and the type of
representation of sex that
men and women typically want to see i
was going to ask you a question which
kind of
alludes to the same answer but it's like
if you were to create a point because
you said there's men there's now
sites emerging which are like female
friendly i'm like what's the what's the
what's the difference what what's how do
they
i suppose well you know one of the
things that um a lot of these sites
they're creating
is a focus on kind of female pleasure
in a way which is that what we know for
example is that the majority of women
um or like the most common way of
bringing women to orgasm is through
direct literal stimulation but for
example in
not necessarily porn but in the movies
we never see that
and so then everyone is kind of
replicating what they see in the movies
and no wonder it's not quite working so
i think that there's also
educational elements starting to kind of
come forward and a lot of that kind of
content as well
i guess that makes sense if the demand
for pornography has
been skewed male then what you're seeing
in the pornography would also be catered
to what a male
likes to believe is
you know men as you like alluded to that
men typically get their
arousal from like what do they call it
vaginal penetration
i guess that's not intercourse yeah or
intercourse whatever but
women would typically get reach like an
orgasm via
clitoral stimulation so porn tends to
reflect the
the former um so
has has porn been a a a positive or
negative impact on
um our perceptions and images of what
our
own sexual relationship should be like
do you think oh that's
such a big question is it again it's the
one that everyone wants to know the
answer to i think
that the problem that we've seen is when
people have used it as an educational
resource and that's not how it was
designed
um now what it has offered
is people who are exploring their
sexuality and feel that it doesn't fit
for example the
norm or expected norm you know however
you want whatever terminology you want
to use for that
it's offered those people a sense of
community
or safety in exploring or belonging or
knowing that they're not alone not
isolated in their experience
and so there are you know like
everything in life there's going to be
huge pros and cons and like anything in
life is how people use
anything but i think for me
you know working with people with sexual
problems and relationship problems
isolation or feeling alone in your
experience
is probably the biggest side effect or
negative side effect
on mental health or on the problem
itself
of what they're experiencing of what
they're struggling with
and so combating that which in a way is
where therapy helps you know we're kind
of
sharing that conversation we know that
shame thrives in silence we're starting
to externalize we're starting to talk
about these things
is making people feel they're not alone
is massive i am
one of the things you said i read that
you had said before
which i thought was really good advice
especially as it relates to keeping sex
like fresh and exciting was just to
change one thing every time
um and i wanted to for you to tell me
why
you think that's important and how that
helps it goes back to some of the themes
you've talked about
but it was one of the things that i
thought
i could immediately do in my own sex
life to keep things
continually fresh yeah and what are
those small things that you're referring
to when you say
i suppose what i like about that is it's
actionable so it's this idea
that we can all be like empowered and in
control to
do something in our sex lives and you
know like
one of the the phrases we hear kind of
all the time is that mixing it up
spicing it up and what i think people
get intimidated by
is the idea that they have to do
something massive to do that that they
have to
you know go out like buy a whole new
wardrobe
yeah exactly or try something that
they've like never done before
or you know buy 25 sex stories or
um you know try everything like and
that in itself then becomes a barrier to
people trying it because they're like oh
god that sounds scary
expensive as well but you know like
that i it's that um god like how am i
gonna do that there's no stepping stone
to that it's a whole like bridge a whole
jump
and that puts people off so again we're
back to that avoidance thing you know
what i'll just stay in my safe zone i'll
stay in my comfort zone i'll stay where
i
am like the idea of trying that and it
not working or trying that and it
failing
feels way scarier than where we're at
right now and so i think that idea of
like changing one thing every time
is it's also that routine doesn't
kind of help or promote or um
kind of encourage desire because we're
like oh i know what's coming
i know how this is going to go and what
we're then doing is we're more likely to
kind of let our thoughts wander or be
distracted and we see that with people
you know they're like i know it's going
to go so actually
i wasn't really noticing what was
happening in my body or that experience
i was thinking about like everything i
need to do tomorrow
and so what it does is it works
as a way of encouraging breaking up
routine now these are small things
like having the lights on or having the
lights off starting with your clothes on
or your clothes off
keeping your underwear on or underwear
off using lube or not
you know taking intercourse off the
table for that
evening and just focusing on
non-penetrative sex trying a sex toy
or you know putting even something
simple that i talk about is
putting like your pillows on the other
end of your bed so your room feels
different
like lighting candles changing your
smell having a shower or not you know
doing it in the street you can get
arrested for that
but um you know it's that idea of these
are all
accessible within range non-intimidating
things
that we can try to create
shifts and changes my journey with huel
has intensified
a lot over the last six to 12 months the
the untold story of a healthy diet and a
nutritionally complete diet is how you
feel and really that's a much more
important thing because actually how you
feel
is the sort of precursor to you having
the motivation the discipline and the
state of mind
that will help you go to the gym and
follow through on your goals
and i feel amazing i don't think i've
ever felt better i've never had more
energy i've been sleeping amazingly well
my sort of mental cognition has been
sharper than it ever has before
but i just feel good right and you often
just get to see the physical effects
that having a nutritionally complete
diet could have
but there are all of these other impacts
and other effects which are so much more
important
and as i said are the precursor to the
positive physical
um effects you see so yeah you know it's
one thing
having a podcast sponsor that pays you
money but it's another thing having a
podcast
sponsor who you genuinely believe can
help people change their lives for the
better
is it possible for some you know because
i've got this one friend and i'm sorry
for just rinse one of my friends here
i've got this one friend
yeah this is a problem with being
friends with me you always appear in the
podcast if you've got any slight like
peculiarity about you um and like i feel
like all of my friends
have been mentioned in this podcast at
least once they just don't know where
they're being mentioned
but i've got this one friend who is a
guy
and he i've known him maybe 10 years and
i've
i don't think he's ever had sex and he's
maybe 27 28 years old whatever
and i don't believe he's ever had sex
i've never i've never seen him in a
relationship
he doesn't talk to girls at all or guys
for that matter um and i don't it's just
so unusual because
in our in our friendship group we talk
about sex a lot so we're always talking
about you know who we're sleeping with
in various things
and we've basically just learned to just
not have the conversation with him
or when he's there you know if we're
just like joking with each other as
friends
we will never joke with him because it's
just this big question mark and none of
us know the answer
um and i think my conclusion has been
maybe he's just
asexual if that's the thing yeah that's
the thing
and what is that thing and what and if
you i'm sure you've heard about this
before right
what is what's going on well i mean like
we we don't know what's going on for
that person but you know asexuality is
is some is an identity you know like
people who don't experience sexual
attraction
and what that also doesn't mean so we
have asexuality and aromanticism
so those are two different concepts so
what we can see is that people can have
successful relationships and be
asexual because they can have connection
and
friendship and intimacy and we can see
that people who
um are so we can understand that
it's not a kind of like pairing
necessarily and something i also talk
about is
we can have intimacy without sex and sex
without intimacy now
what a group that i've also worked with
is lots of people who have
such bad sexual anxiety and this is in
no way me saying what's going on for
your friend but
that that limits them in sexually
exploring
or taking their sex life to where they
want to go or dating or seeing people
because
what it can feel a bit like is if we get
on the ladder of for example
meeting someone or dating then we get
closer towards
the source of our anxiety which might be
sex and i think that
people who haven't had sexual
experiences and i suppose bear in mind
you're only
viewing this from your perspective
rather than speaking to the person
you've been speaking to um is that
that kind of it can feel like a snowball
effect of a new
something that i talk a lot about in
therapy with people that i'm working
with this
this snowball effect of okay well the
older i get
the more i feel that this is a worry or
the more i feel other people will judge
me or the
more i feel that i won't match up to
what's expected of me
or that i will get kind of found out and
i think that
these anxieties around sex are also
because what we assume
is sexuality in people so we kind of
assume everyone's sexually active it
goes back to that point about
feeling isolated or alone in our
experience
everybody else is doing it so what's
wrong with me
and that the problem we have when it
comes to sex
is we can't know with people until we
check it out
we can't know until we we're judging
someone's
inside world based on what we see from
the outside and actually what we know
with sex is that
they don't always match up there's no
way of really knowing until we for
example
you know sit down with a therapist and
unpack it or sit down with a friend or a
family member or whoever that is we
share
you know a partner that conversation
with
i think there's also like i was just
thinking then about there's also this
like wider philosophical question of
like what is the purpose of sex
because if you see sex as being you know
just to ejaculate
then you know you might encounter a
bunch of issues there because
the the role that sex is playing for
your partner
might be a completely different one so i
guess at first you have to
understand what role sex plays in
relationships uh to your partner but
also to yourself
like is that how would you define the
purpose or the role of sex what is it
why do we do it and what's it for we're
going to make a sexual therapist have
you yet
are we having my job in a minute i know
you'll see tomorrow instagram page it's
like sex with steve
it's just everything you've said um
so one of my favorite pieces of research
and anyone who's listened to my podcast
or any of the interviews and stuff i
know is going to be so bored of hearing
me bang on about this is
a paper called why humans have sex um
and it was done in 2007
and it identified 237 reasons for why
humans
the motivations for why people have sex
and
there is such a wide breadth of those
and that might be um you know my
favorite my favorite one from that study
is um because i was cold
because i wanted to get warm but we can
understand that you know it might be
because
i want an orgasm because my partner
looked hot because um
i wanted to feel close to them because i
wanted to show them i loved them because
because because because
so the meaning of sex goes be
so beyond the what of what we're doing
but
we are so focused on the what all the
time and then we get so tangled up
in everything that's kind of
psychologically going on for us
and i think that you know sometimes
we're thinking about the why you know
what does it represent in our
relationship if we're in a relationship
what does it represent to us if we're
single
what does it represent to us if actually
the sexual relationship we have is
just with ourselves you know i think
that
thinking about that is such a big part
of us understanding ourselves sexually
there's definitely emotional elements
but there's also like a physical
uh prehistoric maybe evolutionary role
that sex plays right
and has that been somewhat lost upon us
now like
because my body my body you know the
chemicals in my body will start tickling
me and telling me that i'm horny
and then you know that will drive me
into action
you know i feel like the the role the
sort of prehistoric evolutionary role of
sex has been lost upon us a little bit
especially now that you know we have all
this contraception and we can swerve
having kids so i think it's become a bit
of a sport for many people
well sex is about pleasure isn't it did
you know you tell me
well you know i think you know well what
we see is that the majority of the
reasons that people have sex are not to
do with procreation
yeah and also the the problem is
i think something you kind of said
earlier um
was it's so gold it can be so goal
orientated
now again this is where
so many people struggle with sex because
if sex is goal orientated and as you
said like the goal is
to orgasm or to ejaculate or to
finish then what happens if that doesn't
happen
we feel like we've failed yeah and so
what it creates then is this
goal-orientated kind of
pass or fail model for sex now the
complete irony of that is if we're
struggling
and we're focused on where we need to
get to as a goal
the act of focusing on where we need to
get to is actually the thing that is
most
likely to not get us there because it's
preventative because
if we are in the moment enjoying what
we're doing
experiencing kind of pleasure and
sensations and
able to enjoy it then that's actually
the thing that's probably most likely to
get us there but if we're so distracted
by the negative thoughts that are going
on in our heads we're so distracted by
our concerns our worries that is going
to break down that kind of process of us
getting there
because i know a lot of people only
every sentence i say sounds so strange
i think i know a lot of people that
struggle with orgasms but i know i've
spoken to some of my girlfriends and
i've asked i've asked them
if they've orgasmed in fact my one of my
ex-girlfriends
she said to me that she had basically
never had an orgasm in her life
um which i obviously is a guy you find
quite well
well not obviously but as a guy that has
never had that problem i found that
quite peculiar and i wondered why
why some people can orgasm so easily and
then some people are
find it a lot more difficult um in this
particular case my suspicions were that
it was
an emotional thing in fact what you've
just described there about worry
this is one of the people that i know
that's very very tense about the topic
of sex and i just thought
you know my suspicion again super naive
was that they're not
knowing this person um they would
probably not be able to relax
in bed and then when i when they became
a sexual partner of mine
i thought yeah they're just like not
relaxed at all but i wanted to get your
take on why some
some people find it so easy to orgasm
and then some people just can't at all
well i think it also goes back to
almost like the first time you know
early messages about this stuff as well
you know early messages about what it's
like to have these experiences what it's
like to be
sexual you know is it something that's
never been talked about is it something
that's shrouded in shame is it something
that
we um think that we shouldn't be doing
or we think about ourselves a certain
way for doing and so
there's so many components to this as a
conversation
and you know probably um too many you
know longer than we have time for but
there's the idea of how we again think
about what we're doing
how we know and learn about our bodies
what we know and learn about our bodies
how we
discover what works for us and our
preferences so there's the physical
element you know we talk about an orgasm
as a peak pleasure experience
but also how we feel about it because if
we're feeling
shame or embarrassment or that we
shouldn't be doing this
that is going to be something which
again gets in the way of us
being able to fully let go and enjoy
ourselves or giving ourselves
in therapy we talk a lot about this idea
of giving ourselves permission
to be sexual or to let go
or to enjoy ourselves or to experience
pleasure
again this is super naive but an orgasm
is a pretty natural thing isn't it it's
like a
natural physiological reaction to
stimulation
so again super naive just i will just
disclaimer from here on out that
everything i say is largely naive and
i'll stop disclaimering every sentence
but
so one would assume that if you know if
we're struggling to orgasm then there's
something
maybe emotional maybe even physical
that's being going unmet
there might be something physical going
on but you know it's
there's probably like something
emotional going on but it's also about
you know have we learned
to do this like have we learned to kind
of
experience pleasure enough to take us
there and also once we do then we're
like okay i understand
how my body works now i understand how
that feels and
i think for lots the lack of sex
education here is
a huge part of the problem you know
pleasure has historically
been left out of the conversation and
particularly female pleasure
who are your who are your clients who
who comes to you with
the sex issues and challenges the most
normal people with normal problems you
know everyday people for
every difference um genders you know
both men and women i work with both
couples and individuals
i have a lot of younger clients so a lot
of my clients are kind of in that
sub 45 age bracket but i work with a lot
of people
in their kind of early 20s and i think
that the early 20s kind of
30s but also there's there's
a couple of things that are going on one
is that therapy has become much
less taboo in itself and sex much less
taboo and we have this kind of
corner of therapy which is psychosexual
therapy where
i think people recognize that it now
can be a solution or that sexual
problems aren't just
medical that actually there can be
something psychological or emotional
going on
and i think that the idea of accessing
help for this stuff now
has become much more normalized which is
brilliant i think you know and much
needed and there are some amazing
amazing
sexual experts and sexual therapists in
this country who
you know i hope are really being and i
know have really been used by people to
help them improve this part of their
lives and i think that
again a part of it is any other aspect
of our life
we would go and see a doctor
or go and see a physio or go and see a
nutritionist or whatever it is
you know if another part of if a part of
our body wasn't working
we would access help for it without
feeling embarrassed you know if we'd
injured our knee
we wouldn't feel embarrassed about going
to ask someone about that but why when
it comes to sex
do we feel that we shouldn't access the
help and then
the longer we're struggling with that
the more of a problem that becomes
because we don't just have the original
problem but how we think and feel about
it
but is there like is there like an age
range where
people are more likely to go into a
sexual therapist
no i don't think there is then i think
evenly distributed from like
20 to 80. yeah really i mean
and i think you know again it's a bit
about life stages
isn't it you know what are people
looking to explore at different stages
we see for example people might go after
a
cancer diagnosis or cancer treatment or
for example around menopause
or that there are certain health
conditions that impact sexuality or
you know common side effect of a lot of
anti-anxiety medications and
antidepressants are an impact on sex
lives
or it might be that someone is starting
their sexual experiences or they've
had a relationship where sex has been a
problem and they don't want to carry
that
on into their next relationship i think
that it's about
understanding like what has brought that
person to therapy
at that time is a big part of
for me as a therapist anyway kind of
exploring what's going on for that
person what's the trigger
for dealing with it now polygamy
um do you have a lot of people come to
you with
in polygamous relationships so you mean
like polyamory like multi-part
multi-part relationships and what are
the issues typically that um
you'd see with yeah polyamorous
polygamous relationships
yeah i think that it's something that
people have a lot of questions about
um it's something that you know i've
talked about on
my podcast because it's what people are
curious about
um because it's also a breaking away
from our
kind of heteronormative like
mono-normative model
of relationships and i think the big
questions that people have
are how do we do this you know how do we
navigate this how do we manage it and
that's about working out what the rules
are for those people you know
how do they hold what are the rules for
them
that work for them how do they
understand the rules you know rules
around things like disclosure rules
around
things like how much detail do we go
into how do we manage this
but actually communication for lots of
those relationships
is really good because they have to be
really good in order to
manage that different style of being or
you know also just the practicalities of
there being more than two partners in a
relationship
i've always wondered if it would cause a
lot more problems but i guess you've
answered it there it's about studying
selling clear rules and
having effective communication my next
my next question again which i was
really excited to ask you was like
what's the and this is a super hard
question
so just get ready yeah what are what are
the things that
men don't and typically don't understand
about women when it comes to sex and
vice versa it's a hard question isn't it
it is a hard question i was just
thinking i was thinking because i know
men are super naive and we watch
we're exposed to a certain type of media
and content and then we like rush into
the bedroom thinking that
i don't know our partners want to be i
don't know
tied up or dominated or whatever else
and then from the other perspective
you know when you speak to a woman about
sex and what she's looking for
there's obviously she's experienced a
certain type of media but she also is
i think typically again with being super
binary here
typically a woman is is is um
has a slightly different expectation
from the man from my experiences anyway
i think part of the problem in that is
that binary approach
is that if there's something that i
would want everyone to understand it's
that
we can be different but we are also so
similar um
you know and like this idea about like
performance
when it comes to sex is hugely
detrimental to
everyone um and
again probably like what is one of the
biggest things i want everyone to think
about is
the assumptions you know what are the
assumptions that we're making about each
other based on
gender norms and expectations based on
historical messages
how do we break away from them and it
might be that that's a conversation
between those two people
and that's the best way of doing it but
also there's
you know all of these kind of so many of
these ideas about sex is so steeped in
history but we've never asked them we've
never had them challenged so
an assumption being you know a really
historical message that we hear all the
time means something i hear all the time
when i'm talking to people about like
myths you know what are the sexual myths
or what are the sexual rules that you
think are kind of applicable to your sex
life
a really common one is that men initiate
sex
like men are the initiators the sex and
women are the responders now
how does that fit people then when
they're like oh but that's not how it
works for us
or you know a for example male partner
if we're talking about hetero
heterosexual relationships
who is less confident and a female
partner who is more confident
and so actually it's the other way
around but then they're thinking okay
but this isn't
what we think everyone else is doing so
maybe there's a problem here
when there isn't because that's what's
working
for them and you see big distinctions
between the issues that
heterosexual and and homosexual
relationships
have i think that
what same-sex relationships don't battle
with as much
is the gender assumptions the gender
narratives the gender norms
that kind of idea of like men do this
and women do this
but you know there are also kind of
every relationship
struggles in some way with that dynamic
of we're two individuals
how do we work on our differences and
our similarities together that
interrelational part which is what
happens between us
you know how what are our triggers
what how do we kind of what makes us
both anxious or what makes us both feel
secure or what makes us both feel closer
and also navigating that you know that
that's really
the battle that all couples have again
super naive question but i'm sure it's
one of the most popular questions you
get asked which is like
is there a healthy amount of times for a
couple to have sex
per week or whatever i used fiverr
once a month before they became a
sponsor on this podcast
and since they've become a sponsor on
this podcast and i've delved into what
the site does and how all the services
work and the
vast array of things that you can
achieve on fiverr using freelancers
around the world
i swear on this dog's life pablo my dog
here who sat on my lap if you can't see
i swear in his life that i've used
fiverr
at least once a week for the last three
months we've built so
many websites we've designed so many
decks we've had
video clips edited we've had subtitles
produced if you haven't checked out
fiverr before
hit the link in the bio fiverr.com ceo
go to the website check it out and every
single time
i do this podcast one person who dms me
with a service from fiverr that they
need doing for their business
for their podcast for whatever project
they're working on i will pay
for that service to be done for you so
find a service on fiverr that you you
want done
send me a message and one person every
week will have that service paid for by
me
super naive question but i'm sure it's
one of the most popular questions you
get asked which is like
is there a healthy amount of times for a
couple to have sex
per week or whatever and you know one
would assume that changes over time
right because i think i know just
judging by my relationships it starts we
start like [ __ ]
energize the bunny rabbits and then you
know life happens
but is there you know and i hate these
questions because again they're so like
unnuanced and so like narrow but is
there an average amount of times that
couples
you would you know if you had to answer
this question and not swerve it
in this for the sake of nuance what
would the answer be i would like to know
what you
think the answer is i think
again context like i'm going to go into
nuances here but context matters like if
you live
on opposite sides of the world then
obviously there's there's barriers but
if you're living in the same house if
you're cohabiting
living in the same house i think like at
least twice a week
you know once in the weekend tuesday
but where okay so where do you think um
that idea of twice a week would comes
from just
looking at my schedule
wait a minute where can i find time
probably like once in the week and then
on the weekends i have a bit more time
so
um yeah but i mean it obviously changes
over time i feel like i probably have
sex every night but if i you know but
just energy levels and
yeah what's the answer then so someone i
um interviewed
talked about the amount of sex we have
as a red herring
so the kind of regularity of sex doesn't
determine like the satisfaction of it or
the kind of pleasure of it or the
enjoyment of it and i think
what it feels like we've been trying to
do
is find an objective way of measuring
sex
so it's this idea of okay well we're all
trying to find the answer
to sex like how to be good at sex like
what that looks like how to
know where we pitch ourselves against
everyone else and
regularity is one of the only kind of
objective measures we have of that
so it's the one that we kind of will
lean into or we want to know the answer
to
whereas what i would say is i don't
think we do have an idea
of i don't know what kind of modern like
surveys
say there's a big survey that's done um
kind of every few years but i haven't
actually seen the results of that one
yet
but what about the monkeys how often are
they doing i feel like they were like
what are the orangutans doing um i
haven't got a clue
to find out maybe your next guest yeah
like a zoologist or something
um but i think that the the thing is is
working out again and what it what we're
looking for is a measure of like how
we're doing
yeah by knowing that um answer and i
think one of the things is
for some couples it might be as you said
they might kind of work in different
countries it might be every time they
see each other they have great sex
and that's enough like that works for
them
for other couples it might be we have
sex once a month and it's really good
you know we're both enjoying ourselves
and we feel like our needs are met
great for other people it might be once
a week you know i think it's about
determining like
what your normal is or what your what is
right for you
but again the kind of worries and
anxieties and stresses come
from a we're not having enough sex
why is that yeah you know is it because
my partner's no longer
attracted to me that tends to be the
first thing people go to and what's
going on
um is it because our relationship isn't
working is it when we don't have a
clear kind of obvious answer like we've
just had a baby for example
um so there's the assumptions that go
with that why has sex
changed what's going on but also the
well everyone else is having sex once a
week and we're having sex once a month
so that we must have a problem there
must be something wrong with us speaking
of my ex-girlfriends i feel like i've
slightly thrown
several of them under the bus but i had
another relationship
this go this goes back a little bit
further where
i just like fell in love with this girl
in every
other aspect non-sexual so
intellectually in every other way
and then when it came time to have sex
which is actually quite
a little bit later than it usually is in
the relationships that i have
like three or four months into knowing
this person um
there was i don't know how to say this
because it just sounds
i'll just go for it um
the
the
i tend to think especially when it comes
to like
vaginal penetration that it's like a
hand and a glove
and the hand in the glove didn't match
and
again i genuinely thought that i could
have spent the rest of my life with this
person but i saw that as
a like insurmountable object like my
penis didn't suit her
vagina and i thought we can't change
you can't change this um
yeah is this something that people come
to you about
often they talk about like the
practicalities the practicalities
like the hand in the glove yeah i think
it is and you know there are for example
like
conditions that mean that people
can't have sex for numerous reasons so
like sexual dysfunctions
or you know particularly for women there
is a condition called vaginismus which
is where
there's an involuntary contracting of
the pc muscles the pelvic floor muscles
where
they're unable to have sex and that we
think affects about one in 500 women in
no way am i saying that's
necessarily what was happening here but
you know we also know that
that it's about how we
work together as couples how we work
with bodies what would make
things more helpful how we can look for
kind of practical advice
but it's about understanding like okay
how do we help ourselves here rather
than again that assumption of like
something's going wrong because it made
me believe in this like idea of like
there's a physical compatibility to sex
as well
not just like a a desire compatibility
or like you know an experimentation
compatibility but there's like a
physical
um compatibility as well to having like
good sex
where you can just like physically not
be
compatible but i suppose it's then where
how do you
if you want to like explore working
around a roadblock
you know how do you kind of
because that's build yourself so hard to
talk about like i could never bring my i
could talk about
the um libido issue with my partner but
i could never tell
that partner that i wasn't that i was
basically turned off by our lack of
physical
compatibility i could never mention it
so i ended up the end the relationships
i tried multiple times to like fix it in
various ways
and i just couldn't bring myself to talk
about it because i didn't want to hurt
the person
i didn't want to say something that
might hurt them and stay with them
forever
so i ended the relationship on the
grounds of something else but that was
fundamentally the issue i've actually
had two relationships in my life but
like sexual partners in my life that
ended purely because of that but yeah
and i think it's so hard again isn't it
because we just don't know
how to tackle these as topics as you say
like
how do we manage talking about something
or exploring something that we just
have no idea where even to start and i
don't offend the person which that must
be it must be a huge thing in the work
that you do
like not wanting to offend your partner
because as you said it's such a
sensitive topic
and i don't know how i could have
approached that situation without
offending the person
and i think that it's the fear of
judgment like the fear of offending the
fear of hurting our partners the fear of
us not being able to go back
once we kind of it feels a bit like
pandora's box for some people like this
idea of
talking about sex in a relationship you
know like if i open this up like how do
we
close it or i think a lot of people have
the fear of
if i open this up then every time we
have sex
we're both going to be thinking about
this and we're both going to be
completely in our heads and what we know
is when we're completely in our heads
when it comes to sex we're not
experiencing what's going on in our
bodies
and that is interrupting arousal you
know the body's process
of us kind of enjoying you know our body
kind of working with us the kind of
sexual arousal process
and so you know our thoughts are as
distracting as they're kind of being
like someone in the room
that's not the person wearing sex with
or someone actually like walking in or
kind of saying all of that stuff to us
just because our thoughts are not a
physically represented being doesn't
mean they're not as distracting as
something else
and you're completely right because from
then on i didn't say anything
but i carried on trying i thought maybe
you know one bad experience whatever
we'll try again we'll try again
and it got to the point where i was i
was
almost avoiding sex because i knew that
it was going to be an issue
and i started to overthink and as a guy
overthinking is not what you want to be
doing when you're trying to
maintain yourself so
i am so i started having issues keeping
my erection up because
i was just i was walking in i was
getting in the bed thinking oh my
god here we [ __ ] go again and i've
got a you know like are you gonna be
able to get it up because you you really
don't enjoy this and
and that all of that just became too
much i couldn't tell her because i
didn't want to insult her
and i was starting to have problems like
you know being aroused because
it was a big issue and you're right it's
a snowball and performance anxiety is
one of the key things that i work with
with men because
where there is not a physical kind of
indicator
or reason for why they might be
struggling for example with erections
because
getting into your head too much
again creates a speed bump for
sexual arousal because when you're
feeling stressed or you're feeling
anxious
you're in that kind of fight flight free
state your body is preparing not for you
to
kind of lie down and have sex and be
comfortable and relaxed but it's
preparing for
that kind of threat response and that
is not compatible with being sexual in
that moment so in a way
your body's kind of working against you
and so what you have to do then
is work on this kind of like frontal bit
of your brain you know your thoughts
like focusing on that in order to in a
way like reprogram
because sex has become not fun
exciting pleasurable connecting it's
become anxiety provoking
stressful fearful you know don't want to
be here would rather avoid
so in a way the way i describe it a lot
is the meaning of sex has changed so the
way we relate to it has changed
how does one give their partner good
positive
constructive feedback do you know what i
mean like
because i'm sure there's i was thinking
then i'm sure there's so many people
listening to this that are in
relationships
that would like their sex to be slightly
different
and they probably in the same way that i
was anxious about approaching it with my
xxxxx girlfriend
um what is the best way to approach
these sensitive self-esteem
attached topics with your partner not
in the moment when you're having sex so
not just kind of like
in bed like just before because also
what you don't want to do is
you know kind of create like a scent a
further sense of like stress or anxiety
like in that sexual space
so what i always talk to people about is
like leading with a positive you know
like
i really love our relationship like i'm
loving what we're doing
but maybe there's something we can work
on here or how can we do this better
or so leading with a positive you know
affirmation because if someone comes at
you
and um you know we're often really
sensitive to criticism also in our
intimate relationships
and this isn't good enough or you're not
doing this
or our immediate response is defensive
or attacking
we're not open to hearing what they have
to say we're already like shut down
before they've even got there
so kind of approaching it without that
positive
framework or like connecting framework
or open framework and also
let's work on this together this is a
shared venture something
we want to do together some you know
something for us to think about like
how can we go about this because
what can also happen is we isolate the
problem in one
partner yeah when there are two of us
there
i guess i guess another sort of attach
to that would be
just telling them what you you like as
opposed to what you don't like
so it's just like the same outcome but
different framing so it's like oh i like
when you blindfold me or
i don't like when you don't blind you
know what i mean and just making it i
might some of my sort of sexual partners
that have given me positive feedback
in the past have done so by telling me
what they like more of
because then we can lean into that yeah
exactly and we all like to be
told we're doing a good job we all like
to be affirmed we all like to be
especially in sex because we don't have
a reference point
you know are we doing a good job and we
feel you know if we
think we are bad at sex
with that's really personal yeah isn't
it it's brutal you know that's really
a difficult thing to hold on to and then
we go into our next sexual situation
thinking i'm bad at this and actually
what it's more likely to do
is make us struggle and actually when
people are relaxed and comfortable
and calm in those situations they're
able to connect with the other person
more and we're kind of able to
i suppose follow the pleasure path a bit
more or
kind of affirm each other a bit more and
understand that actually someone says
can you touch me here it's not because
you weren't doing it
the right way it's just because that
might be their preference but we cannot
be mind readers we cannot know
what our partners like until we
communicate that with them
that's such a fascinating thing as well
that we never know if we're good at sex
we're just like kind of trusting our and
especially because you see all these
movies and
we read these magazines about people
faking orgasms as a guy i swear to god
the first couple of times someone said
that i was like good in bed or whatever
i thought you're full of [ __ ]
i thought you say this to everybody and
then like i still
i still and i've heard that a few times
whatever but i still
don't know and that's crazy that like
with everything else you have a
fairly um accurate gauge of whether
you're good at it
but because we've never seen like pretty
much we should really
we've never like seen anyone
um doing it in real life or really got
to observe it
outside of the fakeness of porn
and you don't know how it feels for the
other person
and sometimes you don't even know if
they're faking it or if it's real
you can't i th well for me in my mind
like kind of float through life
assuming you're doing okay until told
otherwise
but it also assumes that here we go
again
good at sex is a formula that you can
apply across the board like everybody
it's every sexual experience
is going to be different between those
partners in that time
in that moment in that context it is not
like a universally applicable true
formula
now what we can do is we can
sorry i just passed your purpose but my
ex said i was
like what we can do is we can feel more
informed so we can make no
i consider a big part of my job to be
helping people to make
informed choices about their sexual
wellness and well-being so that might be
you know thinking about the narratives
that have shaped how they think about
sex thinking about their current
definition of sex
thinking about sex education how can
they feel informed about things like
anatomy
things like their body their preferences
their likes and the communication bit
how do i then
communicate that with a partner and all
of that can contribute to better
sexual self-confidence and again what we
know is like sexual self-confidence is
in that person again it's reflected back
to them in situations with other people
but really it's kind of all about that
relationship with self and i know that
sounds very
therapy and something that all
therapists say but it's really true
because
we put ourselves in those sexual
contexts in those sexual situations
for some people they might never
struggle with sex they might have kind
of
muddled through you know like trial and
error worked it out kind of
and always and be okay and they're
satisfied and that's great but for some
people they do struggle for some people
they have a period of normal sexual
functioning and then they start to
struggle
and it might be that they've never
thought about sex really before
until they feel like they have to so
again there's no
kind of one route to all of this
and although there are themes for
example in the conversations that i have
with people
everyone has their own journey their own
story their own experiences that have
shaped that
and some of it can start in you know the
playground like playground banter about
what sex is like but at a younger age
when we're quite impressionable and that
sounds
really scary what people are talking
about we can kind of carry that
with us and then it presents further
down the line or we might have had
a negative sexual experience early which
means that we then don't
want to try again and so we hold on to
that negative experience because we've
had no
in a way like challenging or corrective
or other more positive experiences which
can go against those ideas
we're ever evolving you know humans and
people and
we're changing in every way you know
mentally physically
i think one of the things that has
it's going to be honest because i think
that's just the point i think i think
when i'm honest i think i resonate with
more people
one of the things i'm slightly concerned
about is that at some point in my life
i'll fall in love with somebody
and the sex will be great and everything
and then
me all them will change in that we could
change in a variety of different ways
whether it's our desire but
but more so even like i'm
we might not be attracted to each other
anymore i might
you know deteriorate in some
form and i wonder how much of an issue
that like
two people changing and falling out of
attraction with each other
is um prevalent in the work that you do
in the pit and the people that you know
come to you for therapy and
for advice i think it is it's not
probably the most prevalent thing i deal
with but also
what you're basing that on is an
assumption that that's not something
that can be worked at
it's not something that people accept
when they are
in a relationship with each other or
that they you know i think it goes back
to that relationships moving in stages
and phases
bit as well and i think there's
that's that fear of like things not
always staying the same whereas actually
what i would say is if we accept that
things don't always stay the same then
we
can change and work with that and accept
it
and improve it or adapt you know as
humans we're really really adaptable
but we want to feel encouraged in that
rather than
i suppose kind of put off or challenged
by the fact that we need to
in the world we live in now there's just
this incredible like
perspective perception of choice i'd say
like more so than
my grandparents around i imagine they're
dating their sort of circle of possible
matches extended to like the size of
their like street or village
didn't have tinder yeah exactly they
didn't have tinder or instagram but
now in my relationships if it's not
going well i've got apparently
a gazillion people right here that are
perfect
they're all filtered and i think you
know
32 000 of them just like my photo so if
i lose attraction with my partner
in the world we live in now where we've
got this huge sort of perceived amount
of choice
and accessibility just one swipe you
know it must make
holding relationships together at times
when they hit
you know rocks more difficult than ever
before no
yeah i think that there are often ideas
that like the grass is always greener
but
equally we understand that relationships
take work
and i think you know we we've seen a
breakdown of
norms we've seen that you know divorce
rates are at an all-time high but it's
not the same stigma that it used to be
that kind of people changing their
models of relationships so changing
relationships
is not kind of such a a big thing but
also
something i think is important to say is
just because a relationship
has ended doesn't mean that in itself it
wasn't
successful and i think that's another
thing that we need to
like to reframe you know people can be
in a relationship for 10 years
and it ends that doesn't mean that
relationship failed or was a failure
it might have been for that person at
that time
this is part of the issue in my view
with marriage
because marriage you say till death do
us part but we all know that
if there's the only constant is change
we're all going to change
so how can you honestly make a
commitment that you're going to stay
with this person
why would you want to until death
knowing that you're both going to change
in various ways that are yet to be
seen but can't you also change together
in a positive way
you can like i think i think people are
moving
they can move if you think about it as
like two parallel lines
they can go they could be slightly
tilted one degree
to the the right which means that in 10
years time they'll be too far apart
or they could be slight one degree to
the left which means that in 10 years
time they'll be closer together
um or they could be perfectly straight
right so perfectly parallel which means
that in 10 years time they'll be the
same
they'll resonate in the same way they'll
be as close you know whatever but you
don't know that yet so i think that
that's why i've always been slightly
let down by the concept of marriage
because i think
you know you can't predict the future so
why would you want to make something
like that
so final um and i've i've i think like
you know the men in black have you seen
men in black oh god a long time ago when
they get the pen and they they hold it
up and if they press the button on the
pen basically it raises your memory
i sometimes think i think if if we held
that pen up to the world and erased
everybody's memory what are the things
that would come back
like science would come back religion
would never come back the same
we wouldn't it wouldn't come back the
same right science we would figure all
the same things out
same experiments marriage i'm like no
wouldn't come back the same
not in 2021 i don't think that would
come back the same um i think we'd have
a much more bespoke
open flexible form of marriage that
would involve
less of the law and would involve less
of the church
um and i probably think would be a
little bit more effective
so i guess my question is about marriage
what do you think about marriage
are you married
you know i think that it's what what
does it offer people you know like what
are people
looking for and i think for a lot of
people it's security you know and it's
it's form of insecurity though like i
think i tend to i'm going to play
devil's advocate here yeah i do
because i think if you're looking for
security from like a legal contract i'm
like
then that for me speaks to a little bit
of insecurity somewhere else
but i think it's also about you know i
suppose marriage has been the norm
right historically it's always been the
norm it's always been
also considered the gold standard or
like what we should kind of
aspire to be or aim for and i think that
again you know that that impact of
history like us doing the things that
we've always done
but it's an institution and a lot of
people subscribe to that now
what we see now is that people can be
married
multiple times and be happy in every
relationship or it be perfect for that
stage or for them or for that
relationship that people don't need to
get married that people can
parent and become parents without being
married that
it's i suppose the biggest
um representation of commitment that
historically we've always had and people
now
can find other ways to commit to each
other you know buying property together
that doesn't require it so i suppose
children it's probably the biggest
commitment but it's also about
what those people are looking for
i think i think that's you know people
think i'm really against marriage it's
actually not the truth and
my friends say to me are steve's against
marriage i've listened to his podcast
i'm like no you didn't listen
what i'm against what i'm for is a more
bespoke
um tailored approach to how two people
come together i actually had a friend of
mine
say to me this week that he and he will
be listening to this podcast for sure
he said um he thinks he can only be with
someone for a year at a time
he says after a year i just i don't
think i can
you know the relationship can't go on so
he's having these continual one-year
relationships
and look i guess the most important
macro question is like are you happy
yeah um and people's happiness is
derived in various ways
um i do think i do think marriage is
somewhat
you know i think maybe it's because i
tend to have a perspective that
convention
um conventional solutions um aren't
always
very well equipped to solve new problems
and the world we're living in is a very
new one
we're living longer than ever before
we're exposed to different types of
information we have
much more freedoms than i think our some
of our ancestors used to have
so maybe the the way that humans commit
to each other should not involve the law
it shouldn't take two years to divorce
someone which i think is crazy
um i think it doesn't have to and i
suppose it's about
what people are looking for and i
suppose as you
you know you're asking earlier about
like multi-partner relationships or like
you know consensual non-monogamy it's
about us making informed choices
about what works for us and our
relationships and i mean that's a
conversation i was having with someone
just yesterday
is how do we feel more informed
you know how do we explore what that
might look like in another way because
for some people trying to fit into what
they feel they're expected to do might
not work for them it's a it's a system
or a model that doesn't work
so how do we then start to like open up
that conversation
for ourselves but also
we have our fears you know we're humans
we like to i suppose feel
that we fit the normal fit what's
expected or you know some of us do at
least
that what well other people think of me
if i step outside
that so as humans we have that balance
of like what do i want but also what
will other people think
yeah which i think is typically quite
awful
yeah but it isn't it one of the biggest
things that drives people in a lot of
ways drives them
try somewhere though like i think i just
think in every facet of life it's like
your mom wants you to be a doctor but
you really want to be a ballet dancer in
costa rica
and it's like you know what's expected
of you you know you're expected to go
get married or and then become a doctor
but like your intrinsic joy will come
from going and being a ballet dancer in
costa rica
and uh not getting married or whatever
and smoking i don't know whatever
in the mountains over there but you know
i tend to believe and this is probably
there's no like i don't have a huge
scientific basis for this i have a
couple of like philosophical studies
i've read but
that um people who abandon like their
true selves or
that conform to society's expectations
typically
have some point in their life some kind
of um
moment of realization where they realize
that they've not
not fulfilled themselves as they could
have
isn't this back to that point of
expectation versus reality though
yeah i guess so like the gap between
what we expect and then where we kind of
find ourselves to be or what we
what that looks like because i think
again that's that
and also you know i'm it's that idea
again i feel like i talk about gaps a
lot but that idea that gap between
the person i kind of know myself to be
in the person i show everybody else that
i am
and the bigger that gap the more space
for struggles or battles or mental
health challenges around that
what is and this might just be the title
of this video because i
because i think it will be so we'll uh
we'll clickbait this part
what is the single biggest killer of
relationships in the modern age in 2021
in your view if you had to say this one
thing
is the single the biggest killer of
relationships what would it be
unrealistic expectations one of the
big problems you you talked about it
earlier this idea of like what we see in
the movie so we're like oh that's what
it's like
so then when it's not like that we're
disappointed
our partner fails us they haven't met
our expectations they haven't met all of
our needs you know we talk about
this idea lots of relationship experts
talk about this idea of how we shouldn't
expect
one person our partner to meet every
single one of our needs
but we do and so they're kind of doomed
to fail
then in that way so how do we
change that how do we start to kind of
like open
that up how do we you know we have other
relationships in our lives we have
family we have friends we have
colleagues you know we
need to start to think about like how we
can do that for ourselves
and then our we work with our partners
to create something together i
completely resonate with that and
i think most of my relationships fail
because the expectation that my partner
has on me
it goes unmet because i'm very selfish
and i like to work all the time and to
think about my stuff
all the time and i'm like very
self-absorbed and when i have free time
i just want to like i don't know
do something for me um i've tried over
the years to like
manage that expectation by making it
clear as early as i possibly can
that like work is a huge part of my life
and i am very selfish
selfish sounds like such a negative word
but it means that like i'm so consumed
with my passions and the things
yeah like you could say focused i use
selfish because it makes it
because i'm trying to take a little bit
of blame i guess but i am so consumed
with my passions like i will
work all day and then i'll go on youtube
and want to watch something about spacex
and elon musk taking spaceships to mars
and then
in the morning you know i just want to
do and i kind of want them to do their
own thing as well
so i try and very early on lay that
expectation down
but it just never seems to work because
at the start someone will tell you that
they
oh they're cool with that they're never
cool with that
ever i suppose it's about that you know
relationships are about that balance of
independence and dependence
and so it's where that balance
sits i want independence
i want them to be independent me to be
independent and will like
meet in the middle sometimes but yeah i
i don't know maybe i i maybe i'm the
problem
because i think that compromise is
important i don't think i compromise
very often as much as i should um
i went through my life i think
pretending that
i was just so focused on my work and no
one could deal with it but i probably
think that i'm also like
i think selfish is probably the word and
unwilling to compromise and like
i think so like the negative version of
selfish is also the word where like
i prioritize my my needs more than
someone else's
i think that's caused me a lot of
problems i i sit with people in this
podcast all the time that's super
successful and they
they'll they largely struggle in
relationships
do you think that's because their
primary relationship then is with their
work
yeah and themselves because it meets you
know
we see that right we need people talk
about their businesses as their babies
you know like that's my first baby or
that's my baby and i think that
you know are we for some people we get
our needs
met through our
businesses through our passions through
our
sport through our careers and
for some people they might get enough of
their needs for relationships met
in those kind of smaller doses or not in
those kind of like single
intimate or couple or relational
relationships
but they have that met in other ways
across the board or in kind of
smaller ways now who are we to
pathologize that i suppose
difficult i was hoping you'd have all
the answers i'm sorry i definitely don't
have all the answers i can but
compromise is important right yeah
but in any relationship you you
compromise with people you work with
you compromise with friends you
compromise with family members like we
all
we all have to compromise because
relationships are however many people
there are but you know
if we're talking about couples two
people who are independent different
people trying to work together
and they're not going to perfectly fit
together or be aligned in every single
way so how do we navigate that
when you're running your own business
though and you're the ceo
you don't have to compromise as much do
you know what i mean things tend to go
on your schedule
when you know you get to kind of lay
down so in your and then transitioning
into your personal life
you have to almost perform the opposite
behavior which is like high patience
listening when you're the ceo you can
you know condense things how you want
and
you're leaning into your natural way of
working and things are kind of going at
your cadence
within your how you want things to
happen whereas in your personal life
that that's maybe where i've struggled
whereas like i've learned one behavior
in my professional life which is about
saving time on everything and optimizing
everything to be more productive
and performance-based yeah and i'm like
i don't want any sentence to be longer
than like it
needs to be um so then transitioning
into my private life where
things you know you can shall we go for
a walk a [ __ ] wall
like i'm like what are you doing what a
waste of time what
what for like do you know what i mean
and i think i've struggled with that
transition because
the decision making framework i have
whether that i use at work
it can't be the same it's applicable oh
my god it's the worst
and sometimes maybe it seeps over into
my personal life so they're different
it's almost like different operating
systems exactly exactly
two different objectives do you think
that so if i like
kind of push that back on to that kind
of question of like how
relationships work back on to you then
do you think that
entrepreneurs or people who then kind of
go out on their own
and do that are more prone to that
different way of
relating or more that's their more
natural style
as in do i think they're more likely to
say so just to make sure in terms of you
were saying like you know as a ceo
you're like the person in charge you set
the agenda you set the time like it's
more
you're kind of leading that that in a
way that might be
a piece of being an entrepreneur is
someone who
kind of puts their head down and does
that yeah but and it's also like heavily
learnt
it's like you learn imagine if you put i
don't know they say like you know how
diamonds are made that it's like the
pressure over a million years or
whatever
um you get pressured over 10 years and
you learn
a philosophy for your use of time for
how you want things to happen whatever
um and that becomes part of your
character even if it wasn't when you
were you know 10 years before
when going through that experience it
makes it part of your character where
you're like
quite impatient things you know
typically operate
in the way you want them to so you learn
that personal philosophy
because that's what made you successful
and also that's what's required to
succeed yeah
yeah and i i genuinely
think that it's for me anyway i mean of
course i've got these crazy hindsight
biases but
that's what was required for me to get
to where i needed to get to
but if i want to be successful in my
relationships then it's like all these
other things which is like compromise
and patience and doing things
for the sake of doing them as opposed to
where they're gonna get you
yeah with some kind of outcome that's
what i've struggled with anyway
um but anyway enough about me you know a
lot of stuff
right questionable yeah you've learned a
lot of stuff so how easy did you find it
to implement all of this
stuff that you know into your own life
and in your own relationships i always
whenever i have like an expert in a
specific topic on
i'm always fascinated by their own
ability to apply their knowledge in
their own lives
um i mean i think you know speaking for
myself
in this space like i think we can i can
be a hypocrite i think we can all be
hypocrites in our own ways and you know
that's because
we're also all human you know we all
still have our
our triggers our anxieties our defenses
and
i try my best and i think that you know
that's the best you can do
but i think that relationships there's
an acknowledgement that relationships
take work and take nurture and i think
actually when you try to talk about this
stuff all the time you actually
sometimes need to kind of step back and
be like okay so
what am i doing here you know like at
home how do i
implement this as a partner as a parent
as a family member as
a friend and it's kind of acknowledging
that i'm being thoughtful of it and i
think
that there's also that idea of like how
am i
best working with or serving people
close to me rather than kind of like
everything else something else to do for
me it's
about pulling away i suppose from being
a yes man you know there was a stage in
my kind of life career and i said yes to
absolutely everything and now you have
to be
a bit more selective because otherwise
then you lose the
quality time and i think that quality
time is an important
part and it's actually making sure that
it's carved out protected
um so i think for me that's a big part
of it but yeah i think
not you know what what is the perfect
relationship you know
we're all working at everything all the
time and i don't pretend
because i'm someone that works with
relationships and sex i've not to be
working on it myself
i bet all of your friends come to you
so last night you like did you get that
a lot i think
a bit but you know i think i feel
incredibly um
fortunate that i have a very
you know emotionally open emotionally
intelligent group of friends you know
like i surround myself with the people
where we have those
open conversations we are able to go to
like the difficult places it is very
mutually supportive and none of us
pretend to have it all worked out or
that it's all perfect you know i think
there's kind of a
almost like a celebration of like the
perfectly imperfectness
yeah of it all and also putting our
hands up like wow this week is
tough or i'm really struggling with this
or you know this is going on and i think
that
there's something in knowing you can
pick up the phone and just
say that that is hugely hugely important
do you ever instruct or advise any of
your
patients to this is a [ __ ] rogue
question but i
just came to my mind to go and get
some kind of like training
sexual training is that a thing i've
seen it in like a documentary i think
it's quite
like a place in amsterdam you can go and
i'll teach you how to you know
give someone a hand job or something i
don't know no i think you know i think
the where we're at now you know in the
world is that there are online platforms
kind of creating i suppose like more
instructional
content so there's an amazing one that
was launched by
the kinsey institute which is one of the
leading kind of sexuality research
institutes in the world and it's a
platform called omgs and it's basically
about
helping like instructional videos and
interviews about like
how to um create female orgasm or
stimulate female pleasure
what's the website again
but i think that you know we are now you
know with sexual wellness and well-being
becoming such a big important
topic we're seeing that these platforms
are coming up which are
to help instruct or to help offer advice
and that means that the educational
content is available to people and i
recommend lots of that stuff
because if people feel informed they
feel more confident and that means that
they can have actionable things
to work on to build on and that
they're more able to be like okay yeah i
can i understand how this works
now whether this is our bodies or
someone else's bodies to a certain
extent so that can kind of
help set me up for a
sexual experience
and lastly just to sort of loop around
from the from the start what are the
if you were to say that they were there
were similarities in couples that do
enjoy
great sexual relationship just
principles top-line principles what are
those sort of
key distilled top-line principles um
such a big question communication
communication yeah
is like top of the tree and i think i
think it's top of the tree and i think
it's the one that people don't want to
hear
because it's less actionable and it's
quite
scary yeah exactly it's like
in a way i think talking about it is the
hardest thing to do and
but it is you know any relationship kind
of expert any expert in the sexual kind
of
well-being how space will say to you
like communication
is that and then it's like okay but
how do i do that and
you know we talk about these
communication exercises things like kind
of speaking from your own position so
like
i say so there's a place called the
gottman institute and they have
you know done so much research on
couples but it's this
ownership like my feelings are i'm
feeling
my perspective is because actually what
you're not saying to your partner is you
yeah it's not blame it's not blame
exactly so i think that
the communication part on like positive
communication
is a big part of that but it's that
breakaway from assumption
it's like clarification or assumption
assumption is what trips us up so much
of the time
because we're mind reading we think we
know what our partner's going to say
before they say it so we don't even give
them a chance
yeah that's true well listen thank you
so much for your time i feel like um
it's been a very enlightening
conversation and i appreciate that the
fact that you've taken the burden of all
of my sexual
every sexually show i've ever had it's
good to get it out of that i feel like
this was therapy for me more than
anything else but um
where can people find you and i know
you're involved in a bunch of other
projects i know that you've got a sex
toy project which you're
involved in as well so where can people
find you and reach you
yeah so my website is my name kate
moyle.com at uk i host a podcast called
the sexual wellness sessions where
we have um informative but informal
conversations about
different areas of sexual well-being so
whether that's desire
sexual functioning kind of sexual
mindset
um infertility and sex you know try and
i try and cover kind of
um specific subjects around like what
people might be struggling with
um and then i'm on instagram at kate
moyal therapy but um this expo project
is on the uk sex expert for lilo
so um luxury sex play brand and they do
some amazing amazing products as well so
and i work with um brands kind of
creating like
sexual kind of wellness focused i
suppose
projects or huge products yeah and i
think
brands are really trying to get it right
and i really really respect that i think
that's amazing so i actually love that
work because it feels like it's
taking the learning from inside the
therapy room and putting it out into the
world and hopefully then that's creating
that
social cultural kind of sex positive
shift that i think we all need
well thank you so much for coming on
today it's a real pleasure to speak to
you and i was so i've been so excited
about this conversation for a long time
probably because i've been able to
unload on my own personal issues but
because you're someone that really
um has a powerful insight on a part of
our lives that as you say is taboo
and often not talked about enough and
that's why i thought that was good to
to have this is one of the pages in this
podcast diary so thank you so much
and um i'm sure we'll uh we'll i'll be
in touch
with all my other issues every year i'll
be in touch
just just wanted to say thank you thanks
this is huge news i finally got to meet
my debut book happy sexy millionaire it
arrived from my publisher
last week and it was so surreal
seeing this book after about almost
three years
from the point where we had the idea and
i started speaking to publishers about
it
to the point where it's in my hands has
been almost three
years and i traveled the world to
produce this book i stayed in two
different jungles on two different
opposite sides of the world for 60 days
in total
completely alone completely in isolation
to write this book
i've poured so much time effort research
studying into it i've met mental health
specialists i've met some of the most
successful people in the world i've met
clinical psychologists
professors people that are experts on
divorce
everything and i've poured all into this
book mixed in with my own life
experiences
it's without a shadow of a doubt the
single most important thing i've ever
produced
and it's crazy because you have to sell
a book that's what like fuels the
industry right that's what gives you a
publisher that's what gets
into shops that's what gives you
distribution but if i could if i could
click my finger
and everybody got it for free and it
meant that i made zero i would click my
finger in a heartbeat because i think
it's that important and i just want
people to read it i don't care about the
money side of it it's everything i've
ever learned
all of my most important lessons
distilled into this small book
and i teamed up with one of the world's
leading artists in sort of
visualizations and he produced about 25
images for the book as well
so i know that some people learn through
words some people learn through images
the book is a combination of the two
happy sexy millionaire you can pre-order
it everywhere now
and if you do get that pre-order please
do dm me because i'd love to thank you
myself
[Music]
you